l hôte du monde c'est marine je vais
participer au triathlon de paris en me
mettant de la condition d'une personne
aveugle je fais ça pour vous montrer que
le sport c'est avant tout du partage du
dépassement de soi que c'est pour tout
le monde et surtout peu importe son
physique précaire en al'air moi c'est
bon on commence par la main droite
et ont commencé à trottiner 1 2 3
je vois vraiment rien et j'entends des
bruits qui sont démultipliés j'entends
des bruits des voitures et j'ai
l'impression qu'elles sont toutes
proches dans la musique derrière je sens
beaucoup le seul aussi barthère d'âge
c'est quand même pas s'ils sont durs
après c'est différent par rapport à des
malvoyants ou des passants qui voient
pas eu tout de naissance ou qui sont
devenus parce que là on est arrivé donc
je sais où on est je sais qu'ils avaient
une partie des armes et une partie de
picchio on va dire donc j'essaie de me
repérer mais des gens qui n'ont jamais
rien vu ou qui n'ont jamais ils n'ont
pas la notion de ça dans leur tête c'est
une france encore plus dur
waouh
ce défi je vais le réaliser avec un
guide juliet review il est actuellement
guide pour arnaud grosjean qui fait
partie de l'équipe de france 2 par à
tâtons dans chaque épreuve
quel est le rôle du guide
en natation c'est simple c'est faire le
là
le parcours le plus court et on est
relié par un lien qui va donner la
possibilité d'avoir des informations
parce que si j'ai envie d'aller à gauche
je te tire un peu plus on coince sur le
lien avec la jambe
si j'ai envie d'aller à droite mais je
suis un peu
me serrer contre toi les automatismes ne
font que petit à petit tu décalera 2 sur
l'année
la difficulté va être que les gens ne
soient pas au courant qu il ya un lien
entre nous deux certaines personnes vont
vouloir nous doubler juste entre nous
deux et donc je fais arracher lien
serait vraiment
pas cool du tout bientôt je me suis bien
senti du coup en vélo
la difficulté dans le tandem c'est
partir sur le tandem on met le pied sur
la [ __ ]
c'est bon de 3 ferait partie
pédaler mais faut être très souple c'est
comme sur une moto
au palais contre ce que veut faire le
guide par rapport aux virages par la
souplesse du pédalage et hambourg
saviez-vous ton vol faut que le guide
soit beaucoup plus fort que la tête mais
faut quand même avoir la possibilité de
parler ou pour former
n'importe quel obstacle à gauche on va à
droite savoir les sensations de la tête
malvoyants la personne est comment dire
handicapés visuellement il faut être
proche possible pour que
et plus de sensations
munication paras français
pour cette épreuve nous allons faire 500
m de natation dans le bassin de la
villette enchaîné par 20 km de vélo en
passant par un public et on va terminer
par 5 km de course est jouée à peu de
choses près la distance réalisée sur ce
très attendu paris le tréfonds s par
marine c'est quasiment la distance les
jeux paralympiques
concernant les personnes déficientes
visuelles il y a deux catégories la
catégorie des non voyants et celle des
deux baies 3 qu'on va appeler les
malvoyants je commence à m'habituer
pour une fois je suis pour
l'indépendance
[Musique]
j'ai presque mes lunettes
vainqueur sur les yeux
julienc et là
yaka en forme
grâce à lui je vais faire tout ça
non surtout après
pas une seule
[Applaudissements]
oh
le paratriathlon a fait son entrée aux
jeux paralympiques sur les jeux de 2016
très vite ça a cartonné la particularité
du paratriathlon c'est qu'il est géré
par directement la fédération française
de triathlon
c'est à dire que elle s'est ouverte aux
personnes handicapées un sport grand
public qui dit bah oui on est ouvert à
tous les types de situation ça roule
bien derrière parce que moi clairement
tous les déficients visuels que je
croise ils sont en train de se mettre
plus ou moins au triathlon on ne jure
que par le par atria tôt aujourd'hui
c'est assez rigolo
avec à leur guise
également et bien avec les bleus
la selle est là mais mes chaussures on
est parti
c'est bon on est partis au marchons pour
on tourne légèrement à droite fortement
à droite le bon camp
allez
robben sa mort
perso je vais jouer
ça demande beaucoup plus d'organisation
quand on est aveugle il faut trouver la
personne pour vous accompagner le
créneau où l'espace la salle de sport ou
la piscine sera un peu dispo parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde c'est pas facile ou
les coaches qui prendront le temps de
bien vous expliquer des exercices parce
que quand on vous montre va vous voyez
pas on est où là
oui
ok on en débattra
ça sent bon la ligue braille
gfr
oh
allo
à l'aiguillé on va descendre du vélo on
mais bon
on finit par y
virage à droite
on va mettre en pause le vélo à la main
c'est bon ça
parti pour des cours des cent tout
doucement virage à droite léger
[Musique]
m
je vais très rare aux étendues marines
l'eau à droite
de m 12 oui serré à gauche un petit peu
monsieur tu peux merci aux fous
oui je sais pas dire non
[Musique]
morgan
paratriathlon c'est vraiment voilà un
chemin un chemin de vie on peut dire que
ils ont pris le dessus
peu importe les chronos qui vont faire
derrière ils sont capables de faire
quelque chose que la plupart des gens
n'imaginent pas faire demi tour du corps
d'élite ont deux victoires au tour d'une
course qui va avoir des nerfs qui vont
frôler la jambe de temps dans ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est fini on va passer la
partie difficile passerelle dans vingt
mètres on commence à monter sammonds de
légers au début ça s'amplifie après on
tourne bien mais rien c'est bien qu'on
arrive presque avec m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super
tout ça
[Musique]
faire du sport tout seul c'est bien ça
quand on peut le partager comme la vie
le sigle de vue radio coeur
ça se voit pas sur moi parce que mon
handicap
mon oeil oui et donc j'ai la chance
j'arrive dans mon quotidien ce que tu
vas faire assez bien illusion quand j'ai
tourné repères tu vois je connais par
coeur
le fait d'être hyper proche de bas de
son guide le fait de créer quelque chose
moi c'est vrai que je lis directement
senti avec julien et c'est sûr que c'est
incroyable et je crois qu'il vaut
vraiment le vivre pour le décret et pour
le partage et c'est forcément une
relation un petit peu inégal je veux
dire parce que j'ai gagné beaucoup plus
encore que tu peux gagner dany je pense
qu'effectivement il vous permet
énormément il branche sport accessible
pour tout simplement une personne qui
devient guide doit être là justement
pour partager avec l'athlète des moments
forts et pour être là justement pour lui
faire passer un moment un club qui a
envie d'accueillir des personnes fois
qu'il ya cet état d'esprit d'accueillir
des personnes en situation de handicap
passé hier qu'en fait il a vu l'état
d'esprit
des poumons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]